Oh Bert's easily distracted
how are you know come on Tyson is
walking in oh is Bert Bert didn't
realize that this is radio and he could
have just continued on The Tonight Show
you know one saw him walking in he was
coming quietly ready just sat down I was
I'm 50 no I'm a guest walks on in The
Tonight Show every would look oh my god
this guy just walked on but in radio he
wasn't just kind of command you and
finish your story can I tell you
something
Bert's entire face look at his face or
facial structure it's red he looks drunk
always look he's completely starstruck
yeah last time I was here you were here
and you gave me the brilliant analogy of
how far the earth is from the Sun which
is like walking across a classroom maybe
I was wrong about Earth to the Moon
burning yeah you would you do would have
been vaporized
you got this sighs like 12 feet away
teach you stuff you got to remember it
accurately otherwise I look bad you know
the Sun is about 12 feet away we had an
astronaut in here who did not give a lot
of information let me ask you there's a
telescope going up it's gonna be better
than the Hubble where is that going to
be in space I telescope going
information let me think let me say what
I think you're trying to ask let me just
tell you what you're trying to ask yes
we have a tour bus
[Laughter]
not at all okay it'd be like walking
from one end of the classroom to the
other so so this is telescope called the
James Webb Space Telescope which is it
had long delays and it's launched and
it's cost overruns and this sort of
thing but that's not that shouldn't be
surprising when it's a unique object a
unique piece of hardware it's not just
off-the-shelf man it's something it's
never had done before so that's gonna go
a million miles beyond the moon hmm and
in a very special place in space but how
many classrooms is that right four times
the distance from here to the moon or
the other side of the Moon moves about
about a quarter million miles away okay
and so so that will especially tune to
observe the formation of galaxies in the
early universe see that's what I was
trying to ask that's what I was asking
this astronaut and that's the question
no you should have been here we're
sitting here we're talking to this as
spaceman we're like he's been in space
Jim goes and Jim phrased the question
even much better than he did he did with
familiarity to you but with the spaceman
you were very specific with the question
and the guy goes Jim says do you know
where that's gonna be and the guy looks
at Jim and he goes uh in space the thing
astronauts when that when they go into
space
nod I if you take a school room globe of
Earth and say like what do you think the
space station is orbiting you know
compared to the 12 inch school room
school people like put their hand the
foot away or something
no it's 3/8 of an inch above Earth's
surface that's where the thing orbits
Wow above the surface of not there so
globe let me explain 3/8 of an inch so
so here's you remember that guy the Red
Bull guy yeah Felix Baumgartner
hock the space jump yeah okay where is
he jumping from one sixteenth of an inch
above the high twenty thousand feet
right whatever that I did the math it's
a whatever that the height that because
that means I have to trust your foot
measurement there but whatever height he
was it was a sixteenth of an inch
we got to get real like a crack team of
researchers going he's looking and
people just another thing one other
thing the pictures they show ya the
curvature of the earth that's complete
BS what it's complete via earth is flat
so if you have a fisheye lens yeah any
horizontal line when representative will
go convex if that horizontal line goes
below the midpoint it will then go
concave sure so in all of the images of
Felix Baumgartner the horizon line is
above the midpoint of the picture so
he's not high enough to see and any
curvature fisheye lens as you see with
what's to the right into the left is the
right lens to use I'm not arguing that
but but if you gonna think the curvature
is the curvature of the earth you've
been duped by optics and they didn't go
out of their way to tell you that that
was not the case want you to see it's a
hundred twenty thousand feet by the
mouse correct it is okay yeah and so I I
tweeted at the time yeah three different
pictures of a fisheye lens taking a
picture of the Earth's horizon and you
see a convex flat when it's right at the
mid plane I just had a beach scene do
you get the beach
take out your fisheye lens put the
horizon of this ocean above the midpoint
at midpoint and below it and you go
convex flat and concave but I don't
think when these pictures came out I
don't think anybody realized it was only
a sixteenth of an inch
I did what do mean anybody well anybody
regular P normal folks no yeah so it was
so I was a little I was what were I
don't have a word I was concerned
perturbed but I was ruffled yeah that is
such a big point was being made of this
yeah so let me not fault the red bull
and Felix and the bravery and the and
the hardware necessary to pull this off
and the balloon and all is fine but if
we're getting that excited it means we
were not doing anything else in space to
have justified
having gotten more excited right alright
so in my in my generation we went to the
moon and back and we haven't been to the
moon since 1972 the guy jumps out of a
balloon 100,000 feet up and everybody's
getting excited I guess the guy tells me
there's not something else to get
excited a guy John if we have people
walking on Mars right now do you think
anybody would be paying attention to
felix baumgartner
no a guy jumping from that height I
don't know whose records did he break
you know no I don't Joe Kittinger he
jumps from I think I see a documentary
about no I height I'm terrified of
heights so that I've Joe Kittinger out
there jumping out an expert on space
he's not an expert on free Falls here's
my freefall right so here's my flow
here's what magical man these distances
above the Earth's surface to an
astrophysicist right are not space it's
just not space to me space is going
someplace space is Earth that is the
moon Mars and Beyond asteroids comets
the distant planets on January 1st the
new horizon spaceship that went past
Pluto a few years back found another
target out there in the Kuiper belt of
icy bodies and it's gonna hit that it's
going to arrive there some potty-mouth
people around here so the double-ended
double-duty
going past Pluto and then they redirect
it and then it hits another object in
the outer solar system so to me that
space what about that thing that's
tumbling towards our our solar system
it's a ninety five thousand miles an
hour I think it's a long cigar object
and they did the Harvard paper did
something on at CNN talked about it what
do they said it could be an alien origin
however I'm not authorized to comment
further on that right Troy happens to
know that Neil knows a little more than
he's telling us about the time of the
Time Square
times lol more which is Hawaiian for a
Scout first scout and it's a it's an
asset some form of asteroid space object
that is the here's why it's important
it's the first ever object known to be
hurtling in from outside our solar
system and otherwise it is not
gravitationally bound to the Sun whereas
everything else that we have discovered
comets asteroids planets are all
attached to the Sun's gravitational
telling some fans are saying yes yes yes
because if you're coming in from outer
some outer outer space right beyond our
solar system you're gonna have speeds
that are in excess of anything the Sun
could contain and so if you give earth
that speed we would then escape and go
to another solar system what happens in
that entrances and what about the
picture they've shown us right is an
artist's rendering of a photo that sucks
and so they just said hey man what do
you think it would look like and he's
like I don't know kind of like the
Millennium Falcon the actual thing is
like this tiny little dot in a in a
larger photo fuzzy fuzzy grainy photo so
here's the thing
what made it interesting object to
justify a paper by two of my colleagues
is that its speed and its trajectory are
not quite fully accounted for by the
gravity we already know is operating
within our solar system the Sun Jupiter
you know that the big the strong-armed
gravitational attractors there and so if
it has a path that is not entirely
explained by known sources of gravity
maybe it's got some propulsion going on
in it
all right so somebody fired it so if
it's got some propulsion maybe it is
under it has agency it's got control
either from some distant place or from
with you home okay so we're getting
attacked okay we are Dave exactly but
then I could hiding their arrival
well they what are we gonna do okay well
so the thing is so so in science what we
have learned over the centuries is the
FIR
explanation that you might want to be
true if it is an extraordinary
explanation that involves magic
mysticism or something that's never
happened before you take my little green
man or little green women yes little
green life-forms that's right yes
then you history has shown it has not
been the right explanation right right
so going forward because we find out
what it actually is right it's not
everything your imagination wanted it to
be so yeah that sucks for sci-fi writers
and the guy with the hair that sticks up
on ancient aliens don't know what it is
doesn't mean you then know what it is
right right okay right this is the great
this is the great problem with the UFO
sightings the U stands for unidentified
not alien life-form just an identity you
didn't know what it is okay as soon as I
heard UFOs like aliens investigate
further I'm not gonna stop you from
trying to figure it out buddy had a
video camera today right you know show
me the abductions and show me the screen
into the town square just drag the
sucker into a town square
that's after like Will Smith did he
opened the hatch and I thought the
funniest scene in the whole movie any
other point is so the these researchers
in their last paragraph I think it was
made the suggestion that an explanation
could be this kind of extraordinary
account and I'm saying it could be
something more natural like it has Isis
on it and it got near the scientist now
controlling its dollar objects we should
have been in space Isis got up there
before us
sorry I'll read pronounce that Isis yes
Oh like ammonia ice water ice
but what a friendly thing that can
freeze I should swear there's more than
one ice jack on the rocks that's just
regular rocks not specify your rock
distract me what you were talking about
magic no way wait he just shut me up a
cure another way my hand did I shut up
this could have extra propulsion is yes
it neared the Sun it evaporated some of
the ice and you have outgassing of the
ice this is like a propulsive force rock
what Jim does in the morning in here
yeah and I do bounce off the walls also
do I so it's a lien in the sense that it
seems to have come from outside of our
solar plane using the word in that way
right that's a perfectly legitimate but
not like it's an alien flying alien
technology right no I'm not saying it's
not that I'm just simply saying it
that's your first explanation right be
prepared for that to likely be wrong
given the history of this extra how big
is this a spell how I suppose the memory
you can do you can google that and where
do you think when do you think it will
arrive where around where we are I don't
have the latest trajectory on it or it's
not coming to earth no I know but I mean
yeah I thought we were under attack I
thought it was gonna hit us that's my
free times as long as what I can you
move that screen long as it is wide oh
sorry no there's no I don't know how big
it really is but is it how close to
gotta come to the earth you've any idea
I did I didn't come and no I don't have
those numbers in like three classrooms
curious what were you guys talking about
before I walked in nanotechnology I'm
wanting a young girlfriend to be
impressed which is why we all want a
young girl from to be impressed with the
cool things we can now do it or older
person Bert's married but he'd like to
find a young girl well what do you want
young but no know anything about
anything and enough forage its percent
us as you get older yes I get wiser yeah
this is something to be chair
yeah and isn't it odd think about it
that when you're young all you'd want to
be is older and then when you're old all
you want to be as young yeah that's
messed up that's that it means we're not
really fully in touch
Neil Burgess with the arc of time that
we occupy Bert just found out the Sun is
more than 12 feet away and you also the
older you get the more you have to offer
so you can get girls that were
unattainable at one point that's a big
thing too you get those girls are
unattainable and now you can get them
and you want them I don't and by the way
just to be fair to my wife I don't want
to have sex with one of them I don't
want them to be impressed with me and
you want to grow who knows stuff but you
want a girl who you can impress with
cool knowledge like my very minimal
knowledge of space that you go I hold on
a second I want to grow to go wow that's
kind of cool that you know that and you
don't want to have sex with them either
Jim right that's all I want to do yeah
and my knowledge wouldn't be of anything
smart it would be like oh they're about
to bring out cookies at the end of our
flight they bring out warm cookies just
want somebody to be impressed by me at
all at all literally at all and it's
weird because that's how I got her was
impressing her with whatever little
stuff I had sure and now that I can
actually impress someone like you have
[Laughter]
Conan has a hand in it Conan not Conan
oh sorry yes I guess he has something to
do it's doing a show your comedy yes I
guess so yeah that's right that's right
have you tried to get a meeting with the
president to get him to focus more on
NASA like because you say we want to you
know send people back to the moon send
people to Mars it's gonna take money
somebody like you okay I don't I don't I
don't approach politicians ever they're
not targets of interest for me but we
they're the ones that are paying for
space no we are the citizenry so as an
educator my targets of interest is the
electorate not the people who they elect
so you're trying to get the people to
kind of push and caress because if you
if you start going after politicians
then
that's what lobbyists do Kim Kardashian
got that woman out of jail yeah they're
not your representative there's somebody
else's representative and I feel very
strongly that I should not be
influencing the person who other people
elected to represent them
you should be influencing the people
themselves what that's interesting yeah
so so not that I should be influencing
them but as an educator I feel some duty
to help people come to as informed a
decision they can regarding their
opinions as as is possible otherwise
people are voting with no real sense of
the causes and effects of things I get
you because if you're going up and doing
all of this work there like it doesn't
matter who we vote for neil degrasse
tyson's can take care of it anyway no no
I add Carl Sagan once noted that he was
not a big fan of superheroes because it
just gives us all an excuse to sit down
and let other people do all the work
right so it superheroes is
anti-democratic in that sense I have a
question for you too that the astronaut
was totally incapable of Anderson went
into space okay
I know that he wasn't a good of a guess
yeah he didn't he just kind of sat there
last night but we just got the 37,000
feet so I asked a question about
nanotechnology because I don't where
they go to get cancer four months into a
three-hour mars trip so if
nanotechnology that can kind of go in
you stammers in your blood and that's
basically what it is it can monitor like
you said what happens if you get cancer
four months into a three months Mars
three I'm a three year trip four months
into a three month what type of
technology are we gonna have that can
kind of patrol your bloodstream and
check for what's going on and actually
understand the genome and and here's a
really for me an interesting
philosophical point your control over
things to build to edit to delete to
manipulate is almost entirely related to
the size of the tools you're using
relative to what it is you want to
control right so hold on don't say right
like you understood
blinking over here and you're like oh my
god two equals so if you're going to
repair a watch uh-huh it watches the
thing that used to sit on your wrist and
have mechanical things going on in the
perfection right you're going to repair
a watch that people forget what that is
you can't use a hammer and pliers make a
more normal plies or direction because
that's these tools are too large right
right to interact with the machinery of
a wristwatch too delicate little you
need little square as they are okay to
fix things that might be in your car oh
yeah the things you're fixing the car
other than circuit two nowadays circuit
boards are larger than these tools so
the tools can manipulate them right hey
if you're going to build a home and
you're gonna lay down bricks you need
tools that can manipulate the bricks if
you use these tiny wonders and the tool
yes okay right yeah all right
so this is the super high thought by the
way okay
is only look at everything now no it's a
whole different thing so if you want to
if you want to manipulate cells or
molecules that construct cells you need
some kind of tools that can operate on
that level you can't go in there with a
hammer and a chisel okay so this is why
nano technology Nano is the metric
prefix for a billion is that small that
that's what the th gets you basically
twenty five million nanometers in an
inch is that right from the screen did
you already know there's a scrolling
screen of research up here they did that
can make you look way smarter than you
might actually be it makes us look
dumber cuz we just end up kind of just
stuttering through those you listen
that's a sheet of newspapers about a
hundredth of a nano meter inch can you
make that bigger so yeah but I mean
eventually they're gonna have things
that can destroy cells it just things
that will keep your health going when
you have so as as our tools get smaller
wait it opens up a much wider portfolio
of things that you can then alter with
the with those tools so that's why it's
that's why we try to use biological
tools against biological but that's why
we have sort of the white blood cells to
attack invading germs all right
so so and we can do things to help our
white blood cells do this but that's not
our tool it's a biological tool imagine
if we made tools that small that could
then do these things so you're you're
four months into a three month trip to
you're diagnosed with cancer so then you
just take the cancer pill that sets into
motion tiny tools or engages your
biology to then fight but it's not
hammers in the bloodstream if you need
to know what you're looking at perhaps
it's that like kind of like in the movie
Fantastic Voyage
thank you other if you remember that
that's a story from Isaac Asimov this
back in the 60s
a brilliantly conceived where there's
some important I forgot the details some
important diplomat that has a brain
tumor and they got to keep him alive so
they shrink down the Proteas which is a
ship that goes down and they inject it
into his bloodstream it either they have
like laser things and they have a doctor
and definitely wait what was the one
with Martin Short that was the same
thing a father of the bride no no no
Martin talked about Honey I Shrunk the
Kids Martin Short and in Dennis Quaid no
me nobody knows that was your bill oh
wait that's Andy Rooney what would make
you Rudy the same movie oh yeah there's
a face in her space yeah I got it I'm
obsessed with the idea that you can't
fix anything with something bigger than
it but do that that's the that's it's
great this is all generally true thing I
[ __ ] love that only gonna be a shirt
by the way this that that that
philosophical fact is echoed in the
mantra of construction workers they say
any job is simplified if you have the
right tool right and the right tool is
not only that the shapes fit but it's
the right size tool for the
guys and yeah so I think about this all
the time but between what is possible
and what is not wormholes I want to ask
you about wormholes yeah better segways
you're you know everything so it's like
alright how about a wormholes he doesn't
know that and he didn't know how to
pronounce a conan he certainly does not
Conan the Barbarian so now that
wormholes is will we ever be able to
actually see one or travel through one
or send anything through one man sin one
we know about the mass of a wormhole so
we've got that on paper and by the way
I've I try to be clever one day in early
days of Twitter like my probably my
hundredth tweet I I was in Charlotte
Airport one of these airports where I
had to go from a big plane to a little
plane and it was like miles I swear was
miles and I I tried to be close I tell
the story before you live in the country
so I get to the other it gets with a
small plane gate and I said let me be
clever and I tweeted I can't wait till
we have wormholes that that way all
gates will be adjacent to one another
and you just take a step right that's it
then there you know if there's none of
that and so someone tweeted back dr.
Tyson the day we have wormholes
you won't need airports oh I just got
Tyson microscope drop fair point is
right in my memory as a brilliant double
point there so so here's the thing we
can know how we know we think we can
make a wormhole the problem is they're
highly unstable right it's like
balancing a marble at the top of a hill
you maybe you can do it but anything
will send it down in one direction or
another
so anything will collapse this wormhole
against your wishes so keeping it
propped open is a very delicate hard
task and so so going through it you
might get caught in a collapsed wormhole
and that that would be ugly
what happens if acum wall collapses I
mean what exactly is your opening up oh
yeah yeah so you you're opening up a
path through the space-time continuum
and
involves a higher dimension to do that
and when you do that you can get from
one side of the galaxy to the other
during the TV commercial
basically if that one you actually in
the wormhole that you could be crushed
by it oh so so oh so not very long right
you know right because the work
depending on couple of seconds yeah yeah
so but still we're talking about the
energy and the effort it takes to keep
the thing propped open so so but know
that wormholes are mathematically and
physically it in the laws of physics
possible how thing is why we're
perfectly happy seeing them in sci-fi
movies how big of the ones that they're
talking about possibly trying to create
well you want to be able to sit in it
without getting squashed so that makes
it even harder to have a big wormhole
want to put a bus through a wormhole
rather than a than a you know a a grain
of sand these are different that's more
it takes more energy to do that because
what you're doing is you're curving the
fabric of space and time that's all it
takes some concentrations of matter and
energy to do that how close are we to
see I know the Hubble was they wanted to
see thee at the birth of time how close
are they to seeing that and will this
new telescope possibly see through
whatever it is they're trying to see
through so there is a light barrier and
know that any telescope that uses light
cannot see past that barrier it's called
the error of recombination and there's a
300,000 years after the Big Bang itself
we can't sit use light past that point
but there are other kinds of telescopes
that don't use light that do have access
to before that point so how close
actually no telescope also a
gravitational wave telescopes in
principle can see or earlier back in
time than that so we're going pretty far
back but our confidence in the Big Bang
comes because we can write on paper what
would happen to matter at the
temperatures and pressures that existed
back then you say that we would get this
much hydrogen this much helium there's
so much lithium and it would be this hot
today and you do all of this and you say
oh my gosh this is what we see today so
that gives us confidence looking back in
time to two epochs before we have data
to tell us about it you watch black
mirror yes I've seen every episode which
which is the wood episode do you watch
and go like yeah that's that's pretty
accurate so as you know they're all part
of the same cosmology all of the
episodes
sure sure sound confident when I said it
sounded it sounded like the the response
stupid men
no no it's they all take place in the
same universe okay the same word yes so
the news station it's the same call
letters when the news shows up in one
show as a dozen and playing the same
song in many a music they refer to the
same technologies yes the ability to
move that just to be clear a dark mirror
black mirror is a series was a limited
series only have a couple of years
posted on Netflix right so and it's not
modern but I think slightly more
disturbed being version of the twilight
zone and it could happen with melon are
there any principals on there that you
go like so what is a given in all those
episodes but in almost all of the
episodes is that you have access to
people's consciousness and you can
insert consciousness or extract
consciousness just by going up to a
person's temple and putting some small
nano device and taking it out and then
you can put it in a box right you can
alter it you can reprogram it you can
have vision through that person's
consciousness on a monitor so I I think
it's it's it's allowable sci-fi I can
imagine a day where you know
consciousness is a removable thing but
not so nimble
and not so commercially invoked right
that cuz that feels a little much to me
but it's sci-fi so you you give me you
like the chef all right you know Dark
Mirror blackman blackman I'm sorry black
mirror it kind of sticks to you mm-hmm
four days after yeah as you can't sit
because the the themes are so disturbing
and so and like only I think only one of
them has a happy ending and the rest
really and by the way Twilight's almost
like that not many Twilight zones had
happy endings
poor guys glasses broke glass broke he's
a reader and he wants to breed and he's
locked in its then and and there's a
Holocaust yeah the books are saved he's
the only person left
he has his lifetime to read he can
finally do it he had no time before
there's only as really bad I said he
bends over the glasses fall off his head
and they cracked couldn t I went to the
I got in new glasses first that was
annoyed everyone is dead Oh first go go
get him Oh before this extinction level
Holocaust bomb right blows up let me go
get extra glasses no no no no but before
you screen coming no you like still get
on a pair of glasses coming because
they're delivered by intercontinental
ballistic missiles that enter re-enter
Earth's atmosphere hypersonically well
you get a second pair of glasses because
why not have a pair of glasses I was
once the bomb went off go look I want to
read let me go grab some glasses he's
already got glass and just be clear he's
alive because he was down in a safe
better safe when it happened plus the
glasses stores got blown up yeah I guess
they did yes you too but my point is
that was a sad disturbing ending yes and
a commentary on the Cold War culture
that we were living in in the 1960s and
70s
I'm just saying about black mirror the
access we have to human consciousness is
it is a given in most of those episodes
and I find that particularly intriguing
Ray Kurzweil talks about singularity and
eventually having people's consciousness
uploaded to computers and he thinks by
2045 that'll happen I think he's wrong
with the time frame what do you think
he's right about that I do I think it's
time for results and and you're basing
your judgment on what because I gotta
get this wishful he's a really smart guy
and I think he makes great sense about
mapping DNA a lot but I think he wants
to live to see it because he always
always be careful someone says that
another person who invented stuff that
is far beyond me is a smart guy but Ryan
you are you about aliens and he's just
getting stoned wanted in the stupid
cable show and you're actually an
asteroid watch that that could you got
to you video all this right yes he
watched that episode and we and I did a
lot of talk in there and I should have
given you a little more chance to talk
but there was a point where you just
looked you just like I got angry with me
and you would not you it wasn't oh we're
done thank you for joining you just you
just you just shoved the microphone away
and walked away
as though you didn't like my answers and
and for me you shouldn't judge you
shouldn't invest emotion in what is
discovered to be true in the world he's
right telling me he is right we do nails
right on now it's just either is or is
not and and for me if the aliens are
real great okay how could they prove an
alien was real to you
sounds like it's not about proof it's
about bringing enough evidence such that
doubt gets mollified or removed entirely
okay because it still could be someone
in a little costume for example right
does it's not a matter of proof here
proof is a very specific word used in
mathematics and in logic in science we
just get evidence to the point where
we're good here let's keep moving on
okay all right so so people will loosely
use the word proof in science but in
fact we is we don't prove anything ever
we just show that it's not really worth
your time and energy and money to keep
researching it because the evidence is
overwhelming so yeah a living alien or
dead alien brought in so we can look at
its DNA and find out that it's not some
hoax because there's huge interest
especially financial interest in a
successful hoax that someone might be
perpetrating so be great if we had a lot
more footage of people because everybody
has a video camera had a lot more
footage of people having getting
abducted or about to get abducted
because it's not like oh now I have to
take it to two one-hour photo to get it
developed again to drive to my to my
friend's house
no you upload that stuff while it's
happening right stream that on Facebook
yeah go on Instagram live as it's a very
good point proportionally amount of
abduction and alien videos we got in the
70s versus cameras if we have licked it
out okay daily a billion photos are
uplifted to the Internet every week a
billion yeah okay
where are the millions of those if if
the sightings were objectively real that
had been reported on very easy
explanation and I'm not saying I'm not
saying that these people were not
actually abducted I'm saying you need
better evidence than your eyewitness
testimony to convince a skeptic that's
all sir any technology
zip in and out of wormholes is it could
all see that's how they do it they just
zip it out could easily stop themselves
from probably being filmed to play
devil's advocate it seriously advocate
not doubles up anybody who doesn't fall
for that evidence the other day I saw
you right yes the devil is like using
real data to pass judgment on right but
I do think common sense if you have the
technology to come in through a wormhole
and leave through a wormhole or then you
have the technology to somehow not allow
yourself to be filmed but I'm not even
the giant UFO conspiracy guy I just
think that'd be okay saying is the
aliens have a conspiracy to never be
photographed
no that allows you to still believe that
you're right and everything or say and
so all I can say at that point is it's
it it's not sort of scientifically
useful if your best evidence if your
best card that your best hand that
you're playing is that the aliens erased
all photos that you took like is it's
not I'm giving an explanation but you
kind of have to look at possibilities as
to why that we're not getting photos
exist I would say if they're that clever
then and they're that good they would
have never accidentally crashed on earth
hey what kind of alien is that B they
would have such a cloaking device at
that that you would have never seen them
in the first place he's right it's
possible to and unfortunately he's a
busy guy he's gotta go I don't have any
a little bit history here in the days
before people imagined aliens because
our access to space and Technology is a
modern thing and aliens with technology
is a modern thing in terms of what we
invoke to account for it writings we
might not otherwise explain in the early
days when you would have dream sensual
dreams mm-hmm so the way people explain
that maternal emissions you time
nocturnal emissions you are men and
women right so the women it was an EQ
bus okay and the man it was a succubus
so an EQ bus
saying that when under your covers at
night I have all their albums
I've had many nocturnal emissions about
Incubus yeah so an incubus is something
that seduces a woman overnight and a
succubus is something that seduces a man
okay this is these are words from
antiquity so the point is they don't in
many cases you don't see what this is
but you just feel their presence about
it that people have reported you feel
something it's there is that feel of
present just recently that says she's
had sex with ghosts there's a whole new
story on this and so so we know that we
like called prostitutes so if it's in
your head that's an interesting
phenomenon that's going on okay so we
need psychologists to look at it but if
it's aliens who otherwise have a
cloaking device but when they actually
interact with you you feel this then you
could then argue using Jim Norton
philosophies yes that these are aliens
who are preventing you from ever seeing
them but as they interact with you they
can't prevent you from feeling them that
make sense so then the aliens would be
invisible suck you buses and incue buses
if we if I want to try to keep you in
that conversation we've gotta let me
know but just real quick do you think
that rakers wells time is off or is this
timeframe accurate or no
so I remember watching Star Trek first
iteration in real time because that's
how old I am
sinking a warp drive sure yeah I got
that that's in the future and photon
torpedoes got that check replicator got
that a machine that heats food instantly
okay that's certainly in the future pre
microwave ovens of course and wait a
minute they just walk up to a door and
it opens all by itself
nah that'll never happen so I was the
thing I doubted most was that a door
could know that you were approaching it
right and then just opened so you
shouldn't use me as a judge as possible
in the future but all I can tell you is
1903 December 10th you know what
happened
sure from our
I want to spoil it you see 1903 December
tense Kitty Hawk North Carolina oh just
go right brother spit I go for the
Wright brothers flew in a powered craft
for the first time we have flown before
in gliders but those were not
interesting feats of news
okay that was December 10th mmm 1903 so
now let's add 65 years to that and we're
walking on the moon well so I am no one
to tell anyone that something is not
possible in just a matter of decades
from now